well we were supposed to be allowed by
law
to observe the counting of the ballot
now observe means to any intelligent
person
being able to look at it the way it's
interpreted by the
democrat crooked machine of
philadelphia is that the observers
can be 20 or 30 feet away
never able to see the ballot itself
never able to see if it was properly
postmarked
properly addressed properly signed on
the outside
all the things that often lead to
disqualification of ballots
or make it very easy to dump 50 000
totally fraudulent ballots
because they're not observed this went
on for 20 hours
while all of you thought there was some
kind of legitimate count going on here
in philadelphia
it was totally illegitimate so we went
back to court
and we went before a democrat judge no
need to tell you what the result in
philadelphia is if you're before a
democrat judge
obviously a political hack who doesn't
know the meaning of the word observe
observed means to be able to look
not a single republican has been able to
look at any one of these mail ballots
they could be from mars as far as we're
concerned or they could be from the
democratic national committee
joe biden could have voted 50 times as
far as we know or 5
000 times the ballots could be from
camden
philadelphia unfortunately and would say
this about my own city has a reputation
for voter fraud
you have a reputation for dead people
voting and we're going to go look at
just how many dead people voted here
i didn't think we'd have to do that but
we will and you have a reputation for
people being bussed in from camden
voting here
wouldn't be the first time that happened
but this goes way beyond
any of that and let me also add
that this isn't happening just here we
have exactly the same lawsuit in
wisconsin
where exactly the same thing happened
except in
wisconsin mysteriously at four o'clock
or three o'clock
in the morning about 120 000 ballots
appeared
oh here come these ballots
well we have no idea if they really are
ballots
we have no idea if they're signed if
they're postmarked properly
if it isn't just the same person who
submitted a hundred thousand ballots
and they all got counted
this is the way they intend to win now
i'm informed by
former congressman sweeney who's been
going around the country
collecting this information that similar
situation in arizona
similar social situations in nevada and
a similar situation what am i missing
john where are you
in michigan in detroit michigan
again let me be specific what it is this
whole new thing that never happened
before in our country these mail-in
ballots
which has been a cause of real concern
for everyone because they can easily
be fraudulent well one of the things
that the law attaches to that is
the right for both parties to observe
the ballot
the way we do with absentee ballots you
make certain it's properly signed
on the outside there's a signature you
make sure that it's properly postmarked
you make sure you make sure that it's uh
properly addressed
and then you pass on it a number of
these are often challenged by the
democrat representative or the
republican representative we never got a
chance to look at a single one of them
the gentleman here who was who did this
for us says about a hundred thousand
ballots went through that process
in the 20 plus hours in which they
wasted his time
by not allowing him to see a single
ballot
well that's 120 000 ballots that should
be
just be taken out of the count so you
want to look at that number
that 120 000 should come out and this is
an area in which biden is getting
60 70 percent of the vote i don't know
if
i i don't know this is going on any
other place
but it is going on in enough with enough
frequency in wisconsin we've brought
suit
and now we'll have to look into three
other places what it says to me is
this is a concerted effort
of the clerks to run the democrat party
and you know these big city machines are
crooked
you know that 20 years 30 years 40 years
50 years
100 years of one-party rule leads to
corruption
of all kinds voter fraud is one of the
biggest because that's how you keep your
power
but we're not going to let them get away
with it they're not going to steal this
election
this election gets decided by the people
these people the elite they don't care
about the people
the people of the deplorables the trumps
you know they're not important to
president trump
he's the whole reason that he ran for
office
and he's the whole reason for which he's
carrying on this campaign
so that your vote can mean something so
that your vote doesn't get wiped out by
a
hundred thousand fraudulent meaningless
paper ballots
that no one gets to observe
we are going to continue the lawsuit
here we're going to bring a second one
and then we're going to bring a federal
lawsuit and we're going to take a very
good look at whether
we bring this nationally we certainly
are going to bring it here and in
wisconsin
quite possibly we'll do a national
lawsuit and really expose the corruption
of the democrat party but this is beyond
anything i've ever seen
before this comes when you think you
have so much power
and you own the media that you can do
anything you want
well sorry we're going to fight for the
people we're going to vindicate
their right and the ultimate result is
president trump has won pennsylvania
i've never heard of a count where
you're ahead by 400 000 with 80 plus
percent counted
and they haven't called it for you yet
they called california
the moment it could open the polls
closed how many votes do you have to be
ahead
to win for a republican to win here how
many votes do we have to be ahead
400 000 is not enough with
80 plus percent counted i think there's
only 14 percent of the vote to go
do you think we're stupid you think
we're fools
you know something the democrats do
think you're stupid and they do think
you're fools
and that's why you get called deplorable
and chumps
it's over we're going to stick with this
we're going to win this election we've
actually won it just a matter of
counting the votes fairly
so i'd like to ask the former attorney
general of florida pam
bondi to explain what's been going on at
the polling places which is just as
dastardly and just as
criminal thank you
good evening everyone and as eric trump
said we are thrilled to have won
pennsylvania with 87
of the vote in and we're up almost 400
000 votes
so we're thrilled you asked well why do
we care about the rest of the votes
because it is about the integrity of
this election and every vote as
mayor giuliani said in every state must
be counted fairly
what we have seen and we have a video of
it that we will release
to you they put up it looks like a
police barricade
all the way around the perimeter and
they are keeping our pole watchers back
approximately 30 feet
at least 30 feet you can judge for
yourselves they would not let them look
any further there is a gentleman there
by the name of seth
bluestein who is an assistant to a city
commissioner and he is wearing a badge
the size of a baseball
and as far as i know he's not a sworn
law enforcement officer
so it looks like intimidation to me with
a police barricade and a man wearing a
huge badge around his neck
he told them they can't come any closer
he said the reason
was because of i he they can't interfere
with the process and then something
about covid well we all know at the
polls
you have to stay six feet apart our pole
watchers have no problem with staying
six feet away
um yet they weren't allowed to do this
so we're going to release that video to
you
because we oh then they also had
binoculars our poll watchers brought out
a pair of binoculars
they were shut down on the binoculars
but then they were told well okay you
can use the binoculars
so that's a concession that we are
allowed to
observe the ballots yet clearly when you
see how big the room is
you cannot see every ballot you can only
see with the binoculars the ones that
are closest to you
so that's a concession by them and
they're still not letting us see this so
we need to fix this we need to remedy
remedy this now because we've won
pennsylvania
and we want every vote to be counted in
a fair way thank you and i'd like to
introduce corey lewandowski
[Applause]
you know general bondi and i will be
here for the remainder until
you all realize that president trump has
won this state
we have now officially declared the
state of pennsylvania trump country
until the last vote is counted uh
general bondi and i will be here
i'm sure he'll be in constant
communication with you we will be
releasing that video shortly
and we appreciate your time there'll be
no question say thank you very much
jeremy this is a gentleman i'll have him
introduce himself this is a gentleman
who
volunteered two days of his time
in order to do a civic duty and was
obstructed
in a horrible way by the crooked
democrat machine of philadelphia which
really has been around so long it's a
shame
hi uh thank you mayor uh uh jeremy
mercer and i've
i was at the polls or at the uh
pre-campus yesterday from 7 a.m until
just after midnight back again this
morning just before
8 a.m until around 2 30
and as has been described
very well we're there
supposedly observing but we can't see
we're
further away than i am from you all here
hundreds at least 100 feet away from
open ballots that
go back out of our site we can't see
them we don't know what's happening to
them
it's just there's no way for us to
meaningfully observe the process
from where they have us could you tell
us how many ballots
approximately went through that process
that you had no chance to observe based
on the accounts that we've heard
it's about 125 000 maybe more
well so that should be deducted from the
count
those are those are ballast of accounted
in violation of the law
without an observation and since this is
a novel procedure this mailing thing
observation is particularly important to
satisfy the
possibility that you can defraud this
isn't as if you come in and show an
identification
so that's what we're going to be seeking
here and in with
in wisconsin and quite possibly
nationally if there's as much evidence
in arizona and nevada and michigan
no questions right now thank you thank
you very much guys really appreciate it
thank you
you